well it seems like the world has already
forgotten about the mass murder that
just took place in waukesha wisconsin
the bite administration finally decided
to pretend to notice they sent the first
lady and the second gentleman down to
pay their respects
two weeks after the murders
so why have our leaders in our media
been ignoring what happened in waukesha
right after the kyle rittenhouse verdict
sean duffy is a former congressman from
the state of wisconsin he joins us
tonight sean thanks so much for coming
on so this just inherently mass murder
is always a big deal why is this one
being ignored well for something to say
i appreciate you covering the story
tucker for wisconsin but also waukesha
is a great community they have great
schools they go to church on sunday they
love the packers it's a place you want
to raise your family right but i think
you have to look at the facts of the
case right so you have waukesha it's a
mostly white mostly christian
republican leaning counties so they're
the wrong race wrong religion wrong
politics number one but number two daryl
brooks jr the defendant he is black he's
anti-white anti-jew anti-trump right he
gets in his suv drives it down a
christmas parade route tucker
and kills dancing grannies and an
eight-year-old boy injures 60 people
and here's the problem with the story is
that he has a rap sheet 50 pages long
and he's out on a thousand dollars bail
and so the media looks at that and says
well listen we're supporting criminal
justice reform and bail reform and we've
also said that all the white people
around us all the racists are like kyle
rittenhouse trump supporters those are
the racists it can't be daryl brooks jr
he's a black man who hates white people
so we can't cover the story they totally
ice it out and because they don't be
confronted with these facts of good
people being mowed down by a really bad
man and uh frankly the guy who should
have been locked up in jail uh or not
released on bail
you know i just can't think of a more
precise or accurate way to describe it i
don't think you're reading that off the
screen i'm impressed by how concisely
you put it look i don't want to divide
the country any more than it already is
particularly along color lines
but the disparity between the way this
is covered in the written house trial is
covered you just feel like the media
have no credibility at all like
literally at all anymore well no but
quickly i mean if you look at it you go
how do they cover the the russia
collusion hoax and blm and that's right
the the the january 6th insurrection but
they don't cover the hunter biden a
laptop story and they don't cover this
story right so they're just hacked and
you wonder why their ratings are so low
or why people don't trust the media it's
because i mean there they are and you've
mentioned this it's an outlet for the
democrat party the the radical wing of
the liberals that they support and
that's the stories they tell but you
know what i think people want to know
the story and frankly we should know the
story to decide do we really want bail
reform do we really want criminal
justice responsibility is this a really
good thing for america what are the
consequences of these policies on the
american people we should know that but
they won't share it so we don't know
we're still in the dark
man that's again so nicely described i
agree with that and i think most fair
people agree with what you just said
sean duffy thank you thanks tucker hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else